see if this ball sitting on the ground
on the infield for maybe some action at
home play
straight
bottom part of the zone with a runner on
third not too often you see miguel
cabrera strikeout looking in a situation
like that just find something that works
find a good feel for that breaking ball
or able to locate that fastball whatever
it is
he's searching a little bit
sidearm breaking ball got him and hill
pitches around the lead off single the
wild pitch my way isn't always the best
way i got it
demerit strokes one to left
that was on a rope they're gonna wave
bonifacio home rosario's got a good arm
and
touch it he dropped the ball
and they call him safe at home plate
let's see if we can see it from here
he goes under it
yeah sure he did yeah
it is what it is i mean it looks like
they call them safe so
they upheld the call and the tigers have
the one-nothing lead
first major league at bat for sergio
alcantara
it's his offensive production
that needed a better transition switch
hitter
drives one to deep left
back goes rosario it's gone
a lead off major league debut solo bomb
for sergio alcatra
[Music]
welcome to the big leagues
driven to right center field and deep
chasing it is looking up that ball is
high off the wall to third is kay he's
being held on a double by adrianza
[Applause]
just missed hitting it out
you got a good contact hitter in the box
right now you hope he's able to
get cave in and get adrian's over at the
same time base hit up the middle on the
first pitch
kate will score adrianza behind him and
just like that the twins have tied it
with the bottom third of their lineup or
even better just get them that was it
nice job bye that's the deal right there
checks it with his first hit of the
season couple of you guys
tie ball game it all started with the
lead off walk to cave good at that by
adrianza
duga comes through
driven to right center field carrying to
the gap demaran chasing it he won't get
there
it'll score polanco from second base and
arise slams on the brakes
with an rbi double
his second hit of the ball game
he does a nice job of driving this ball
to the right center field gap the center
fielder shaded so far over
into left center field the only person
that'll play on this ball is the right
i thought maybe he had a chance at a
triple but wisely held up at second
two and one for the twins designated
that's a sharply hit ground ball past a
diving alcatra
[Applause]
some credit right here a little slider
just a little spinner didn't do a whole
lot
[Music]
nice job of keeping this ball fair hits
it hard enough to get it past
first baseman
but now the next man with a fresh count
that's going to left a base hat
[Applause]
all three times
an rbi single
and it's six to two if you say deutsche
left in his mind that's a pull to left
right there
the 200 willy castro
drilled to right center that's got some
carry and that ball's gone
wow
splashed into the
garbage bag up in right center field for
his third homer of the season it's a
two-run blast and detroit's pulled
within two that's a big blow right there
for the tigers just keep the pressure up
hopefully they'll fall don't i will say
minnesota has stood up too
there's the single you're looking for
bonifacio's gonna have to hurry
rosario's throw the plate not in time
and grayson grinder delivers with two
out and the tigers have pulled who they
won
good answer
down by four now down by one
well just the fight that this team is
showing right now
to center field and down
[Applause]
[Music]
a nice job right there being able to put
that ball in play hidden soft enough so
fell in front of the center fielder
picks up an rvi the twins answer back
pulls it down the right field line and
that's gonna drop
a run will score candelario on his way
to second he's got himself an rbi double
and the tigers have pulled back to
within one
got the slider kept his hands in down in
the corner
scope scores
2-2
rifle to right that should tie it
candelario scampers home willie castro
does it again we're deadlocked at seven
how about the gumption by this team
debbie i love it i mean they're down six
two right they look lost they look done
they bounce back
minnesota reclaims a two-run lead and
the tigers
answer again
driven to left
deep back goes rosario he's at the wall
he leads and it's gone
a home run for grayson grinder a solo
shot with one out of the eighth his
third of the season and somehow the
tigers have taken the lead
1-0
it to left into the corner that's a fair
ball and that skips up and that's a
ground rule double for jonathan scope
we'll take it it's going to be an rbi
triple for jonathan scope and the tigers
lead by two
cabrera the other way
making a three-run lead
after the rbi single from miguel cabrera
the add-on runs vital for detroit here
in the eighth looking right where he
wants it
brian garcia a chance for his first
major league save
the old one
popped up
right side
camario
squeezes it this was a character win for
the tigers
down 6-2
they charged back and win it 10-8